is there a possibility in your mind that
d-hop fits and kirk could all get a
thousand yards
[Music]
uh yeah for sure um
i definitely think um i definitely think
that's possible
[Music]
uh and you know what it's now a thing to
look at three teammates that can get
over a thousand yards even though it
hasn't happened in 12 years 2008
cardinals they made it the super bowl
that year by the way larry fitzgerald
anquan bolton steve preston each over a
thousand preston barely over a thousand
but it happened thanks to our friends at
nfl research for pointing that out
yesterday so
what we're gonna do today we're gonna
draft the teams most likely to have
three players not necessarily receivers
with each in excess of a thousand just
three teammates who go over a thousand
yards from scrimmage this year can be
running backs can be receivers can be
tight ends can be anybody that's today's
draft and my understanding is shereen
has a very easy and simple what color is
blue type of trivia question for me
today
absolutely mike so here it goes who was
the last receiver and the only one since
1960 lead the league in receiving yards
with fewer than 1 000
it's got to be drew pearson
it's got to be what year was it
probably
1975. yeah it was 1977 he had 870 yards
the only time since 1960 that's happened
very good
that was what color is blue
yeah well no because i knew it was going
to be silver and blue crammed up my uh
football memories um from 1975.
and let's have a point of clarification
here because i mentioned a thousand
yards from scrimmage for running backs
are we doing a thousand yards combined
from scrimmage or it has to be a
thousand yards rushing or a thousand
yards receiving for the running back
okay thousands are either or rushing or
receiving so not from scrimmage all
right well i look i'm gonna pick the
trio that's already done it
right they did it with a lesser head
coach than what they have now they did
it with freddie kitchens otto beckham jr
jarvis landry and nick chubb last year
all three had over a thousand beckham
and landry were banged up all year long
they're healthy now of course
everybody's healthy now for the most
part but if they did it last year
there's no reason to think they can't do
it again this year so give me the browns
beckham landry and chub
the only reason i do have them as one of
my first or second picks and the only
reason i say that they won't do it this
year is because they have more weapons
than they had last year they have austin
hooper they have kareem hunt for a full
season so this might be a team that has
too many weapons where they spread it
out too much where odb com
commands the ball demands the ball
and they have to pass it to him but i do
think cleveland is right there simply
because they did do it last year i think
you start by looking the teams that had
the highest offenses last season the
most yards and that's dallas baltimore
tampa bay san francisco those types of
teams cowboys led the league in offense
with just under 7 000 yards so we're
talking almost half their offense and
they did it last year too they had
ezekiel elliott amari cooper and michael
gallup and this year they have cd lamb
and i guess that's the only thing you
worry about them not getting it as they
have too many weapons but they did it
last year i think they'll do it again
this year i think they'll put up a lot
of yards and contend for having the most
yards in the nfl this season
i'm stunned that you would pick the
dallas cowboys trio although that would
have been my other first pick i almost
thought about taking them just so you
couldn't but yes when you look at and
they can actually have four amari cooper
recently said he and michael gallup and
cd lamb could each have over a thousand
yards receiving and i think it's a given
that unless he's injured ezekiel is
going to get a thousand yards rushing
all right uh now it gets a little more
challenging i'm gonna it's not
necessarily out on a limb
i i am going to wager that given the
decision by damien williams to opt out
in kansas city that's going to guarantee
clyde edwards hilaire delivers on the
promise that made him the only first
round running back this year gets a
thousand rushing yards although with
andy reid you never quite know you may
not get the ball enough times to get a
thousand rushing yards but edward
hillaire
tyree kill sammy watkins in kansas city
would be my next pick because i think
for hillary now with watkins you know
the injury bug is there but he's in a
contract year he's got the motivation
edward hilaire i think is going to get
his thousand he'll hill's just going to
just show up and get his thousand
injury whatever he's still going to be
fine
well i i don't yeah i i
with a tight end i'm i'm reluctant to
say a thousand yards receiving i'm just
relaxing
last year
i know it's just not easy as it is with
receivers though i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna go
watkins hill and edward solaire and if
kelsey does it too then it's just icing
on the cake
okay
i'm gonna go with the team that ranked
second in offense last season and that's
a baltimore ravens and you may give me a
little astra cure because one of those
guys who went over a thousand yards last
year was lamar jackson in rushing and he
may or may not do that again
this year and you know i think they've
got enough weapons with mark ingram and
mark edwards and hollywood brown
and lamar may be rushing for over a
thousand again that they're able to do
it so if i'm gonna pick three of those
i'm gonna say mark ingram and lamar
jackson since they're they're built
around the run and i know they have jk
diamonds this year too and devon
duvernay and all that but i must go
hollywood brown lamar jackson and mark
ingram go over a thousand yards
yeah i i would not be confident that
anybody in that offense is going to have
a thousand yards receiving but if
anybody does it's hollywood brown and
they're very excited about how healthy
he is this year last year he had a big
impact even though he was still
recovering from that foot problem that
that really yeah it helped the ravens
get him where they got him because it
hurt his draft stock because he couldn't
do anything prior to the 2019 draft and
ended up working out very well
for the ravens all right um boy i can go
a lot of different directions here um
i i'm
i'm very tempted
to go
dalvin cook adam thiel and justin
jefferson but with a rookie receiver you
never know what he's you never know what
a rookie receiver is going to do i'm
going to play a little safer and say
alvin kamara michael thomas and emmanuel
sanders with the new orleans saints i
and i know with camara the idea of a
thousand yards rushing is probably a bit
of a stretch but he's in a contract year
and i i feel like uh they're going to
get the most out of him in this contract
year unless he gets a new contract
before the season starts but i i feel
like they really want to unleash this
guy he wasn't healthy last year and he
still had a fairly solid season when you
combine rushing and receiving but i i
just i feel like this saints offense
this year the last time they're getting
the band together with drew brees sean
payton's going to have them dialed up
and they're going to generate some big
numbers and i think emmanuel sanders
going to make a huge difference and
everybody's gonna be trying to stop
michael thomas and they're ultimately
not gonna be able to stop him they can
slow him down they're not gonna be able
to stop him so i'll take those three
guys
boy it's tough for this last pick as you
said there's a lot of different
directions you can go i even had some
teams that that maybe you wouldn't
quickly think of like the raiders i
think they've got a chance to do it uh
the 49ers obviously have a chance to do
it atlanta has a chance to do it but i'm
going to go with the buccaneers and we
didn't even talk about the cardinals who
were the last team to do it and who were
openly talking about doing it but larry
fitzgerald hasn't had a thousand-yard
season since 2017. so i'm not sure he's
capable of quite getting there
this year but i'm going to go with the
buccaneers simply because they were so
good last year on offense and i just
think adding brady to that uh and rob
gronkowski uh creates more that now i
don't think they're gonna have a rush or
rush for a thousand yards but i'm gonna
go with gronk evans and godwin to get
over a thousand yards two of those guys
did it last year gronk hasn't had one i
understand in a long time he had 682 the
last time he played uh but i i think
this is a team capable of having three
with a thousand yards
see i think what they're going to do
with gronk is they're going to ease him
in and they're going to have o.j howard
and cameron breit as the main two tight
ends early in the year and maybe trade
one of them at the deadline and unleash
gronk the back half of the season
because you know in 2018 his last season
in the nfl
we had kind of forgotten about him
because he wasn't performing
at the level we were used to but you
know what that meant that many was
healthy for the playoff push and i think
that's part of the understanding they
have in tampa bay you know because when
they first when they first acquired him
in a trade with the patriots i thought
oj howard's out and then i thought you
know what maybe he's not out maybe gronk
is a guy who comes along more slowly so
i think he's gonna have a hard time
getting to a thousand uh
i also had christian mccaffrey dj moore
and robbie anderson i i just i you know
and i love teddy bridgewater i just i
can't get myself to the point where i
can project a pair of thousand-yard
receivers in that carolina offense i
don't know enough about that carolina
offense at this point with joe brady
running it but but but dj moore and
robbie anderson are both capable and we
know christian mccaffrey is going to be
a given does it count if mccaffrey goes
a thousand rushing in a thousand
receiving does that count as two
and only needs one more one i think you
just get one for that
all right 49ers looks pretty good too
with
i worry about the 49ers though because
it's con you know who's gonna have a
thousand yards rushing for the 49ers
who's gonna do it you never know who's
going to get the hot hand is it going to
be cherry yeah that's
well
no they've had kasharin they've had
they've had jared mckinnon in mothballs
i mean he's been injured but but he
hasn't played at all in two years they
gave him a big contract if he's healthy
you know they talk about the raheem
mustard contract and you got all sorts
of incentives he may not have a chance
to earn them because of jared mckinnon
if it finally takes off so i i think
with for the 49ers it's going to be one
of those things where
after the fact we can look back and say
hey look they had two or three guys at
over a thousand yards but going into the
season i i would not even begin to want
to try to guess at who the three are
going to be because with that team you
just never know
yeah absolutely and they had one last
year which was george kittle and debo
samuel and rahim mozart came close 800
and 700 yards respectively so they were
close but they didn't even do it last
year they didn't have two guys last year
with that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports